[Aplausos]
alguna vez han sentido que miramos en
perspectiva y en el mundo real
que son estudiantes pero por qué
quien nos dijo que estudiar en una
universidad no ayuda al trabajo
lo más importante que nos dijo que ese
trabajo no ha sido dar satisfacción
es muy difícil saber pero todas estas
preguntas me enfrentado mucho tiempo a
media
cuando estaba pequeña yo quería ser
médica
a los dos días no volvían a preguntar
y quería ser astronauta para comprar las
estrellas de pronto
y a veces quería ser hello kitty
y también quería ser cocinera y quería
ser bailarina y quería ser cantante y
quería ser científica y bueno todos
somos así no queríamos hacer un millón
de cosas y simplemente no nos podemos
decidir
y yo creí que seguiría así toda mi vida
hasta que empecé a sentir la presión
para tomar una decisión
y cuando empiece a crecer me empecé a
dar cuenta de que no se valen no se vale
caminar y masticar chicle y no se vaya a
hablar y escribir al tiempo escribes con
la derecha o escribes con la izquierda
pero no con las dos
y no yo
a mis 10 años
empecé a tener lo que yo denomino como
una crisis del día
que estaba alimentada por muchísimos
factores
entre ellos el más importante siendo la
muerte violenta de mis padres están
retenidos
es me basto por completo eso es algo que
te cambia es algo que deforma
pero nadie merece pasar con algo así
para mí el problema no se tratara de que
ellos no estuvieran aquí conmigo
se trataba de que se supone que los
hijos se parecen a sus padres y si yo
tenía mis padres entonces a quién le
parece
me voy en una urgencia por un cambio de
pensamiento
aunque yo no lo quisiera así ellos se
fueron y se llevaron el corazón
pero se llevará mi identidad también
en un mundo de decisiones apresuradas yo
no me podía decidir
los adultos que rodeaban mi vida sólo me
decían que la vida es injusta y yo tengo
que aceptarlo
y ellos tenían razón en una cosa
pero yo no tengo por qué aceptarlo
y así empecé a ser rebelde rebelde no
como un acto físico eso nunca pasó
pero siempre se hace rebelde con mis
ideas rebelde de pensamiento
rebelde porque nos enseñan a hacer solo
una cosa yo no quería hacer sólo una
cosa
mi primer gran acto de rodilla fue
explotar mi creatividad
fui afortunada estudiar en un colegio
que no me dio un molde en el cual crecer
sino que simplemente me dio la libertad
tengo dos hermanas
ambas llevadas por las ramas científicas
y para ellas era muy chistoso ver el
mundo que me se me pasaba por la cabeza
ver cómo bailaba sin música y como
cantaba en el baño y pintaba las paredes
de la casa como cortaba mi roca vieja en
trocitos
para rellenar muñecos viejos
y así de a pocos encontré unas amistades
diseño
empecé a diseñar a trabajar con empresas
pequeñas a trabajar para amigos a
mostrar mis diseños por ahí
cuando menos lo piensas cuando menos lo
espero ya tengo cien mil seguidores un
contrato internacional en mis manos con
dinero que jamás creí podía existir para
una niña de 16 años
aparentemente interviene un lugar para
un más que subir fotos de mis perros
y verlas porque mis amigos
era un trabajo de verdad
con cuentas de millones de personas y
responsabilidades demasiado grandes para
mí
el grado del colegio entonces llega a la
hora de elegir y qatar
y entonces tenía dos opciones tenía el
área donde ya había mostrado tener
talento donde esté seguro me daría un
trabajo y tendría todo ese éxito de que
los adultos
yo tenía mis segundos de que no les he
hablado hoy
qué es la biología
para mí no era importante el éxito que
ella tuviera no me importaba el dinero
que pudiera estar pasando por mi
billetera yo tenía que escuchar al
corazón
ese fue mi segundo acto de rebeldía
empecé a estudiar microbiología
porque siempre he estado obsesionada con
la genética
empecé a estudiar micro debería por dos
razones principalmente la primera para
entender mejor mi origen entender que
era lo que me parecía
y la segunda es porque soy terca y
aparentemente me quiero morir de hambre
[Música]
pero
ese fue mi segundo
empecé a estudiar mi carrera llevaba ya
dos semestres empecé a trabajar como
voluntaria en un laboratorio de genómica
estaba jugando en la mesa de los grandes
estaba
participando en proyectos increíbles me
ponía una bata de laboratorio todos los
días y haciendo eso rutinariamente me di
cuenta de que no
lo que yo estaba haciendo era increíble
mi lucha por cambiar el mundo por fin
estaba tomando forma
y en ese espacio de trabajo me volví una
mujer mucho más responsable mucho más
sabia
pero yo sabía hablar con mis compañeros
de otras carreras y yo no tenía ni idea
de qué era lo que pasaba en ningún lado
y eso no le hacía justicia en el corazón
eso me entristeció muchísimo hasta me
hizo dudar de ese estado poniendo todo
mi energía en el lugar correcto
y ahí
porque con un poco más de pensamiento
cali en cuenta de que
en el mundo real de una mano
yo era solo un estudiante que trabajado
para un laboratorio y eso no está mal
pero yo me di cuenta de que estaba
construyendo proyectos
no me estaba construyendo
y entonces ahí me di cuenta de lo que me
faltaba
siempre había querido generar un cambio
pero nunca me había preocupado por cómo
hacer que el cambio llegue a la gente
y justo en ese momento me topé con el
periodismo
este semestre estaba tomando una clase
sobre guerra y paz
que me abrió no solamente los ojos sino
también el corazón a sentir muchas cosas
a ver muchas cosas y pasa este curso ya
este final del semestre
y nunca había hablado con este hombre en
mi vida fuera de clase me refiero a mi
profesor
y apenas se acaba la última clase de
todo ese mes me aparta a un lado y me
dice necesito hablar contigo
studies y más de lo que pasó
y me dice tú tienes que estudiar
periódico porque tú no puedes ser
egoísta con tu forma de pensar
y entonces ahí
se imaginarán que soy una niña nerviosa
y que yo
porque yo creía que no nacía con un
talento de nivel a diseñar
definitivamente le dicen acá y ya tenía
la biología tenía el diseño como iba a
hacer para cambiar el chip y ahora darme
los de periodistas
bueno pues era muy fácil dejarlo ir
pero la rebelde
no me puedo dejarlo ir
entonces decidí hablar con mi hermana
obviamente por teléfono porque en
persona me iba dando imparto entonces
vaya me
después de hablar horas y explicar lo
que yo no me quería retirar de mi
carrera que solamente quería estudiar
otra carrera adicional
ella se lo estamos súper bien me dijo
que estaba loca
y después de eso
sólo puedo decir que actualmente estudio
ambas carreras porque creo que la una
sin la otra son insostenibles las
iniciales sirve de nada si no se
comparte y no tiene algo significativo
para comunicar no tiene sentido
esto no es una lucha
contra la superespecialización
ese es el punto de estallar
punto de todo esto está la imitación de
que es en la oportunidad de conocerse
porque quieren que seamos sólo una cosa
y yo me rehúso a hacer solo una cosa yo
sé que todos tenemos un sueño que parece
imposible
yo también me he sentido una mujer
pequeña en un mundo de problemas grandes
pero veces
fueron los sueños los abrazos de la
gente las palabras bonitas
y me hicieron recordar que mis deseos
son más fuertes que mis limitaciones
[Aplausos]
no
pero lo último que me queda por decir es
que de pronto una carrera universitaria
en sí les puede dar de comer
pero una carrera universitaria no me va
a dictar el lugar en el mundo con maría
camila casta
y ese lugar bloquearlo así tenga que ir
contracorriente
porque el fracaso mexis
pues es sólo un aprendizaje y ahora sí
[Aplausos]